foreign
years 20 planes 50 ships and hundreds of
people have just vanished in a small
area in the Atlantic Ocean
this is a part of the ocean called the
Bermuda Triangle or the Devil's Triangle
it's an aquatic graveyard where over the
years researchers have uncovered
hundreds of wrecks scientific hypotheses
have been crafted to try to explain what
is happening here the idea the fear has
spread sparking countless books and
documentaries attempting to prove that
there's something strange happening in
this triangle of ocean there's some kind
of a anomaly going on down there that we
can't explain something that goes on
down far far below the deepest
Rays the last rays of sunlight
in this video we're going to explain
what the mystery of the Bermuda Triangle
really is and why this perilous patch of
ocean has captured the Curiosity and
fear of millions of people
[Music]
hey I'm excited to get into this story
because it gets really juicy but first I
need to think today's sponsor thank you
nordvpn for supporting this channel a
VPN allows you to surf the Internet
safely with nordvpn you click one button
and it connects you to the internet via
a different country there's a lot of
reasons that one would want to do this
for example I've been traveling a lot
lately and I've been using nordvpn to
connect to the internet via the United
States so I don't get kicked out of like
my email and stuff it also allows me to
watch Netflix UK but these are just a
few of the many benefits that nordvpn
gives you for a very affordable price
you can also be protected online nordvpn
has a threat protection tool that offers
a wide variety of protections it blocks
malicious trackers and ads that you
don't want all kind of just in the
background you don't really need to
think about it and it is there so if one
of these many benefits sounds
interesting to you go to the link in my
description nordvpn.com Johnny Harris
clicking that link helps support this
channel but it also gets you in on this
exclusive deal that they're doing right
now that's four months for free when you
sign up for the two-year plan oh and you
get 30 days to try it out and if you
decide you don't need it you can get all
your money back thank you to nordvpn for
supporting this channel let's get back
to the Bermuda Triangle
it's generally regarded as this area of
water in the North Atlantic drawn from
Miami to San Juan to Bermuda the mystery
here kind of started back in 1492 when
Christopher Columbus who incidentally is
getting a lot of air time on the channel
lately for better or worse this is where
the biggest light bulb moment of the
century goes off in this guy's head I
know I know the sources are in the
description I'm sorry
can we move on please thank you
anyway Columbus is out there trying to
reach Asia and he passes through this
triangle of water and this is where
things get weird Columbus kept a very
detailed Journal which I have a first
edition English translation of that I'm
not freaking out about because I love
old books did I need to buy this for
this story no did I spend way too much
money on it as an excuse yes but while I
have it let's look at it God look at
this freaking book gorgeous okay anyway
on September 13th 1492 Columbus says
that as he's going along this route
something weird starts happening with
his compass on this day at the
commencement of the night the needles
turned a half Point Northwest and in the
morning they turned somewhat More
Northwest
whoa creepy Chris but it doesn't stop
there he also reported the sea rising
and a strange light out in the distance
he described it like a wax candle moving
up and down
what is going on here
the mystery continued throughout the
centuries in 1606 while traveling
through the triangle a large English
ship carrying 150 Travelers became
wrecked at Bermuda after encountering a
huge hurricane even though this wasn't
mysterious because it was just weather
it left an impression on how people saw
this body of water in fact it is
supposed that this shipwreck inspired
Shakespeare's play The Tempest which
often referred to Bermuda or vermouths
as being vexed or cursed okay but listen
to this one next up is 1881 this ship is
sailing from Liverpool to New York City
when it passes through the triangle the
people on board say that they came
across a ghost ship with no one on board
there are varying reports on exactly
what happened but the people on board
generally reported that some of the crew
decided to get on the Ghost Ship but
then the ships were separated by a
massive storm when they were reunited
with the Ghost Ship the next day there
was no trace of the crew this stuff is
kind of spooky if true but wait we're
just getting started because when you
get to the 20th century that's when the
Bermuda Triangle as a mysterious body of
water started to gain a lot of attention
in February 1918 one of the U.S Navy's
largest ships the USS Cyclops was
carrying 300 men from Salvador Brazil to
Baltimore Maryland the route goes right
through the Bermuda Triangle but the
ship never arrived to Baltimore despite
being able to the Cyclops never sent out
an SOS distress call no wreck was ever
found as one article published a few
years after The Disappearance said
usually a wooden bucket or a cork life
preserver identified as belonging to a
lost ship is picked up after a wreck but
not so with the Cyclops she just
disappeared as though some gigantic
monster of the sea had grabbed her men
and all and sent her into the depths of
the ocean in an official statement the
U.S Navy said that quote The
Disappearance of the ship has been one
of the most baffling mysteries in the
annals of the Navy that's an official
quote again
kind of spooky oh and the Navy boats
kept disappearing in 1941 the USS
Proteus carrying 58 passengers and a
bunch of metal suddenly vanished within
the Bermuda Triangle and then one month
later another Navy ship disappears 61
people on board totally gone but it
wasn't until 1945 when people started to
get really suspicious this is when a
bunch of World War II airplanes were
doing a three-hour exercise over Grand
Bahama Island flying out and then
pivoting back to their Air Base back in
Fort Lauderdale Florida but these planes
never returned and the disappearances
just kept happening a long-haul flight
with 25 people and six crew disappeared
in the Triangle Without a Trace in 1948
and a year later it happened again to
another plane of the exact same model
all in all there have been over 70
mysterious disappearances here in this
little patch of ocean where all those
years ago Columbus noticed something
strange happening with his compass
with time more and more people started
noticing one writer in the 50s said
quote there have been other
disappearances in this backyard sea of
ours and always the record when the
account is finally closed has an ominous
notation no Trace found and then in 1964
the term Bermuda Triangle was actually
coined in an article Vincent Gaddis
asserted that quote C distances are
relatively short referring to the
Bermuda Triangle and yet this relatively
limited area is the scene of
disappearances that total far beyond the
laws of chance
people wanted answers
Ten Years Later this book came out
the author goes deep and he makes the
argument that something is really
happening in the marina triangle it's
not just bad weather this mysterious
patch of water is actually a gateway to
something much bigger and he's not
afraid to explore some alternative
theories about ancient civilizations and
energy that was left over from those
civilizations affecting this area it's
magnets it's crystals it's wormholes
it's The Ripping of space-time these
forces connect us to the physical
potential of our universe all shown to
us because of the mysterious
disappearances of the Bermuda Triangle
no no no no
come on guys
I hope no one was actually following me
down that rabbit hole because you can't
read a book like this
talk about a bunch of mysterious things
and call that evidence
that is not what this is I was really
into this for a moment actually when I
was going through all of the
disappearances until it started to
become about freaking crystals and alien
life coming to save humans from nuclear
fission we can't do this we can't
present a handful of data points even if
they are factually accurate separated by
hundreds of years and call that proof
that this patch of ocean is cursed what
blows my mind is that this book the one
that really put the Bermuda Triangle on
the map sold over 14 million copies
worldwide it was translated into 22
languages despite being riddled with
completely invalidating errors I mean
what come on I'm actually not surprised
I mean look at us look what we're doing
here we're sitting here eating this
stuff up like it's ice cream people love
this stuff mysterious stories and
finding Connections in observations that
we can see and understand I know that at
least for me no matter how data-minded
and objective I am I kind of get intoxic
educated by a good mysterious story our
brains are like built for this stuff
especially when the Storyteller throws
in little embellishments like despite
being able to the Cyclops never sent out
an SOS distress call this tendency is
really concerning to me and honestly
more and more as I realize how powerful
of a tool storytelling is especially
visual storytelling where I can layer in
the music and the visuals to make your
brain think that it is real okay wait a
minute you're asking is this a video
about the Bermuda Triangle or is this
Johnny Harris's current soul searching
about factual accuracy and storytelling
on the internet
it's both but let's keep going on this
Bermuda Triangle story because there
actually is a very satisfying
evidence-based answer to what is really
going on with all these disappearances
here we go
there have been some serious scientific
hypotheses developed on what's going on
here they range from things like the
Bermuda Triangle having a disturbance in
geomagnetism which throws off compasses
and other navigational tools remember
Columbus creepy Chris or methane
blowouts which is a real thing we have
these huge deposits of like methane
under the ocean floor and if these blow
up you get this massive explosion and
then a huge crater that just sucks down
anything that is floating on top of it
that could easily explain it right okay
but then there's the plane
disappearances here's another more
simple explanation hurricanes the
Bermuda Triangle is in the Caribbean
which does seem to have an abnormal
number of high-intensity storms that
kind of makes sense and one popular
theory is that these storms can cause
what are called rogue waves which are
massive waves that reach 100 feet or
more maybe it's those that lead to the
disappearances see this is making more
sense you've got methane gas
geomagnetism tons of storms in the
Caribbean it makes sense that this is a
perilous place for planes and boats
these are scientific explanations that
validate the Bermuda Triangle we don't
need Atlantis and crystals and Aliens we
have geomagnetism and weather systems
rational explanations for the Bermuda
Triangle no no no no no Shine the Light
folks
maybe not fall for this again no another
trap me saying sciency things like
geomagnetism and methane blowouts can
sound like I'm presenting strong
evidence to you
but I'm not I'm saying words I'm
speculating okay so will we ever get to
the bottom of this well yes we can but
not by listening to me tell you stories
about ghost ships and mysterious Navy
disappearances or even 100 foot waves
instead we need to approach this
differently humans have developed an
amazing tool for seeing reality instead
of relying on our own observations which
usually need to be couched as stories
and that are limited by how much we can
hold in our brain at once instead of
this we can collect hundreds thousands
or hundreds of thousands of observations
about the world and they don't have to
fit in our brains all at once because we
can record them over time and then
process and aggregate them with math or
maths and if you did that you would see
that of the tens of thousands of
recorded accidents or casualties at Sea
recorded over the course of 20 years
there wasn't anything out of the
ordinary
it doesn't even make the top 10 most
dangerous ocean regions in the world at
least according to another analysis
another data set we wanted to make damn
sure on this so we reached out to
Lloyd's list which is a shipping
publication who graciously spent months
aggregating data tons of data about
Marine casualties out to sea we found
that 1.8 percent of all vessels
everywhere in the world have some
casualty including mysterious
disappearances 1.8 percent and that of
the
8634 boats that passed through the
Bermuda Triangle there were only two
casualties
.02 percent of the boats that pass
through here had an accident 90 times
lower than the global average that was
for 2021. so yeah that's the evidence we
should actually be looking at and
talking about it's not as tantalizing as
the stories told in this book that sold
20 million copies but it's true
it's what actually happened and the
beautiful thing is you can then go and
look at my sources look at the data sets
that I used and you can interrogate them
and you can come back and tell me that
my data is weak because of the way it
was collected and what was left out
that's called discourse and it is the
foundation of how we know what we know
about the world all of us need to be
vigilant of this perhaps me more than
anyone I'm a Storyteller but I also want
to be a communicator of true information
about the world to communicate to you
and yeah we'll definitely disagree on
what that information means and how
important certain things are
interpretation opinion Etc but I'm here
to make a further commitment to going
the extra mile to gather the best truth
I can to make sure that it's actually
real so thank you for being here for
being a part of my discourse my learning
and to check me on this when I get loose
and to make sure that together we don't
let the power of story get in the way of
the power of Truth
[Music]
hey thanks for watching something I
didn't show in the video was this model
plane that Nick our studio manager made
it's a TBM Avenger one of the Flight 19
plans nuances man I really appreciate
you being here it's wild to see this
channel grow and even Wilder to see the
team behind it expand like there's a lot
of people behind the scenes if you want
to know more about how we make these
videos there is an entire universe
behind the scenes that makes this all
possible and we make a behind the scenes
Vlog every month that we publish for you
to watch if you are a member of The
Newsroom which is effectively access to
scripts and interviews with experts that
I do that I just give you the full
version of custom tracks of music from
our composer Tom and this this BTS Vlog
so The Newsroom is what I'm calling our
patreon it's an extra video you get
every month you also get to have an
influence on what Stories We Do by
voting on polls that we are going to be
doing in The Newsroom also voting on
titles and thumbnails if if anything
your support will allow us to keep doing
what we're doing and more to focus on
working harder for rigor and truth and
Reporting and journalism if you're
unable to support financially please
just keep watching the videos and
commenting and sharing at the end of the
day having the audience here to show up
and be a part of this discussion is the
best support we have so if The Newsroom
sounds interesting to you check out the
links below thank you for watching
subscribe if you haven't already and I
will see you in the next video several
investigators of the Bermuda Triangle
mystery have suggested that alien
intelligences may be interested or even
concerned in the possibility that our
development of nuclear fission for
Warfare may be threatening the existence
of civilization on our planet as it may
have previously destroyed other
civilizations on this and other planets
the time span of rational man on this
planet of the intelligence potential and
compare terrible to that of today makes
send back 40 50 000 years oh this is
good [ __ ] dude